[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live laura cognito
here i am podcast launchinggaming.net
who is this fine gentleman we have in
the realm of tax east
i'm sydney developer of fast price
challenges watch for a child now for
those who don't know more stride
challenges what type of game is this
just a basic overview
you have to see it as a mix of doom
track mania and super meat boy
nice mix it makes me seems
special say lag base but it's very short
intense level and you have to
rush your way to the hand crushing your
enemies
nice we like the sound of this
so so let's get right on into this we
got lords now though tv in the building
playing some more stride challenges so
let's get right into it
so i'm assuming this is our tutorial for
beginning
you did it
you did it
first final step okay
all cool so right now watching our
challenges except early we're in the
early access version of the game just to
be clear right and um just tell us a
little bit about the stage for the
development right now
so
right now there are 48 levels for the
early access
plus uh some bonus level and also what
we call
big [ __ ] level
bfl
what you know about the bfl though
no doubt the speed of the game is
blistering fast now is this part of
another part of the theme kind of over
top and then also
just basic narrative is there a
narrative behind wall street more tried
challenges that they get the gamers need
to know about
you are in a
kind of post apocalyptic world where
there's a
company that took control of the
planet so the protectorate of man
they discovered some
compound on a exoplanet okay and their
plan is to take it oh okay so we built a
simulator to replicate the
condition of life and the
space
of this planet okay and so
you are basically a new recruit in the
army and you are training in this
simulator
okay so with a new army recruit we're
trading so currently right now lloyd
sedando tv he is going through the
tutorial getting his feet wet so again
basic controls from fps standard um what
any other specific features in this fps
that makes it unique or different from
another game
you get the classical weapons but you
got also some powers
so
you got the slow motion okay that is
giving you
better aiming
there's a shock wave to crush your
enemies
there will be a grappling hook also
and
the last one is the stone
so
you will stomp on the floor crushing
your enemies gotcha
all right cool we're gonna see what's
going on
you're good to go
so we do we're still doing our tutorial
here doing a fire jump and
i think we gotta we gotta work on our
jumping
we're gonna get it all right so we jump
off the platform the platform so the
interesting is that you have platforming
aspects in the game which is really cool
especially the fast-paced nature of it
which is really cool
overgrown feed over trump
please see master races like less down
right now it's okay it's okay
this is why we like controllers
but that's their haircut here's the jump
right here take your time all right all
right oh the overjoy
if you press jump longer you will go
further so if you press it longer okay
yeah also so if you just want to yeah
the moment that light bulb goes off
nice and from this tutorial so let's be
getting our jumping we're getting our
feet left how many stages of this
tutorial is there before we can kind of
get into the main aspect so we still
have a little ways to go yeah uh i think
it's
the last one okay just last one we just
turned okay
yeah
shift is actually the crouch button
there's it's another one so there's no
wall
and if you shift so if you crouch while
running you will slide
and so it will force the direction for a
few seconds but you will go faster there
we go kitty you're never gonna hit the
end of this all that masturbates tall
this is why we like controller
let's get it going so is this now the
start of the demo i'm seeing
nemesis what is this ad nemesis we wrote
that down vanilla
battle mode as we call it
you can add any friends or streamer and
you will see their ghosts when you play
the game so see it as an async
multiplayer he's got it so what he was
going through i saw that visual ghost
representation ahead of him so that
would be like an example if we added a
nemesis and have a player in their speed
run and that kind of egg exactly okay
the blue one is your own best and for
the tutorials it is just uh hours to
show you the path gotcha
all right let's get enjoy the game now
when you add someone as a nemesis yeah
and it beats your score you will have a
notification to tell you
go back to this level and show him
what's with boss gotcha fair now
so currently right now
we're still in the main part of the game
but this is still
to talk
democrats tutorial
uh it's it's it's the game but it's the
early level so they are very short catch
girls as you can see crystal
controllable yeah
and now the structure my question is
this is the structure going to remain
like that where it's a you know kind of
short bursts and then the end the level
is it that structure throughout or is it
more of a open up into like a
full-fledged kind of a world or game is
it just more level based
no it's it's always a short level you go
and
we got three chapters with different
environments
so this first one is like this
the second one have more vegetation and
the third chapter is more with flames
and lava gotcha okay okay cool cool cool
so we learned it so again it almost has
like a
let's say like a speedwater vibe in a
way and
there's a lot of competitive aspects of
it with doing things quickly and it is
that a lot of the part that adds to the
challenge of the game
yeah but you don't have to be a
speedrunner to enjoy it okay
because i'm terrible at that
me too
so completely what's your feel man tell
us about how you feeling it's the
controls are like once you get used to
the speed yeah it's kind of it's really
nice to see like how fast you're gonna
go yeah it really gives you a challenge
to make it more like accurate right and
as you can see like my certainty are
more different abilities
so it's really nice to see
how
like the environments and stuff how
quickly they're moving gotcha at the
same time you can kind of like focus in
on where you're playing got it and kind
of see what's going on and then going
from there so it's pretty pretty
experienced wasn't actually also in
terms of like weapons do we get more
weapons and we get more robust weapons
than the start off one in the festival
yes okay they are unlocked along the way
okay but
we do choose what weapon you have and
what power you have for each level
yeah each level is crafted individually
and so
we get
you got a three second slow motion and
two stone for this level you got
unlimited shotgun with no reload for
this one
so we're setting the parameters for a
level right exactly actually gotcha i
hear you like that what are any
inspirations you know essential watchdog
challenges any games that inspired the
development and how long has the game
been in development
westward challenge i've been in
development for two years and a half
and about the inspiration
there's a lot of it as you can guess
i i know one with a bfg
exactly
we made a lot of questions of course a
lot of quick we like a lot doom and
wolfenstein nice
and we've had a lot of players saying
that the movement
feels like titanfall 2.
that's my heart right there
right now when you say titanfall 2
you know some of the types of guys like
a little wall running you know maybe
maybe in the future
you don't have to leave i'm just being
silly but look it's a very unique take
i'll be honest you know i haven't i
haven't i don't usually play a lot of
games like this but i understand the the
attachment from this community and why
they love this kind of stuff the
challenge and what could have you gonna
have to do shotgun okay let's go let's
go
do that and again just for this clarity
we could have up to four nervousness at
one time
uh three i think okay yeah so three at
one time yeah but you can change anytime
you want nice and last i want to say the
game really looks good the engine really
looks smooth very fast you know what are
we looking at engine wise what is war
stride challenges what is it one is it
unreal is it unity yeah exactly it's
uefa unity no you eat yeah
yeah sorry an annual engine
yeah ue looks good man absolutely cool
we did optimize a lot of stuff as you
can see the quick restart is really
instant yes
and it's a huge part of the game because
you use that binding a lot no absolutely
now again that's the platform what are
we looking at platform-wise
for watchful trousers currently it's on
steam only for early access
and in one year we will do the full
release with uh egs gog okay and uh
playstation and xbox also my
but it's not finished yet
but you can play with gamepad on pc and
we will improve your support along the
way so you got that you got the lower
cognito controller on pc edition that i
like yeah
well look looks fantastic a lot of
promise here again it's in early access
right now
the ue4 looks good super fast-paced
challenges you got the nervousness thing
going on look man we got to keep our eye
on washer challenges and baby
how far out do you think we are from
release
what do we mean like from full release
how how hard do you think
one year
oh yeah
we're not that far without that phone
no doubt all right a little podcast more
incognito here lost now though on the
gameplay he's feeling it no doubt and of
course check this thing also real quick
where can they go to find out besides
that it's early access is there a
discord is there anything in social
media where they can go to find out more
about what's right challenges yeah we'll
go to discord and
twitter our content obviously okay and
that's it whereas
for the early access we have a level
editor oh we have community levels okay
yeah and we have already
quite a few interesting levels
some already made a minecraft like
parkour level
and it does it do work fine it's very
cool good job man absolute pleasure
thank you so much for your time wall
street challenges want to keep an eye
out for make sure you go check this
thing out man
[Music]
let's go long level
i love his bfl
nice
let's get it
[Music]
oh
bullet time action
see we got a professional now petey
i haven't spent quite some time
how much you work on the game and all
the games so what let's shave his skills
yes yes
little jump no jump
okay okay okay i don't i don't feel too
bad for you now
no okay this is fine i
let's go
get that speed up
let's slow down step
get a platform bang
okay okay i see the lead for that slow
down now i see why you do that kind of
bullet time thing
especially with the platforming shotgun
huh let's go
this is that play y'all this is damn
this is how it's supposed to be clean
nice
fantastic man i love it
now i get it now it's like that frenetic
you know what i'm saying non-stop pace
that adrenaline rush and then you kind
of check your friend's time see
you know little competitive action
you go with it
sharper short bursts of fun yeah no
doubt that's that long level that
exclusive okay what are your teams based
out of
we are in france oh cool but we always
want full remotes
so
there's two of us living like 500
kilometers apart and another one that is
living in malta wow
that's very cool
and it's all summer good you guys put
together something really nice man we're
keeping our eye out for it again
just play watch our challenges check it
out
[Music]
you